let's say last year i put 100 into some
type of some type of savings account in
a bank so this is a year ago
and that now today exactly one year
later that hundred and ten dollar that
hundred dollars has grown to one hundred
and ten dollars so this is now
so if you look at if you look at things
just in the absolute dollar terms things
have grown by ten dollars so i made ten
dollars off of an original hundred
dollar investment off of a hundred
dollar investment so i got a 10
return but what i want to think about is
does this really capture how much more i
can buy with this hundred and ten
dollars than i could buy with that
hundred dollars before can i really buy
10 percent more goods and services today
than i could a year ago and to think
about that let's think about well a
hypothetical inflation rate from last
year to this year so let's say that the
inflation
let's say that the inflation
ended up being two percent between a
year ago and today
if that's the case what is a hundred
dollars a a hundred dollars a year ago
in today's money
in today's
money well if inflation was two percent
then a hundred dollars a year ago would
buy you the same stuff that a hundred
and two dollars would buy you today
so it would be a hundred and two dollars
so what is the dollar return in today's
money
dollar
return
in today's money in the current
in today's money the current purchasing
power
well we're getting a hundred and ten
dollars we get a hundred and ten dollars
and we invested in today's money a
hundred and two dollars
if we look at it from today's terms we
invested something that gives us the
same purchasing power as a hundred two
dollars a day and now it's giving us a
purchasing power of a hundred and ten
dollars
so we've gotten eight dollars more of
purchasing power in today's money so
what was the what is the actual real
return
so let me write it in for real return
and we can do it in today's money and
you could do it either way you could
discount the 110 back to a year ago
money and figure out the real return
there and figure out the the pro the
actual dollar return and and do the
calculation or you can all do you can do
it today in today's money and maybe i'll
do it the previous way in the next video
but the real return is we got up we we
got we made eight dollars over the
course of the year in today's money and
what we originally invested in today's
money was a hundred and two dollars a
hundred and two dollars and so we get
our calculator out
eight
divided by one hundred and two
is
seven point eight percent
so this is equal to seven point eight
percent so even though the nominal
return the the the number if we just
look at the if we just look at what we
got in exchange for what we invested
even though the nominal return was ten
percent because there was two percent
inflation our actual purchasing power
only increased by 7.8 percent